we're told sloan went on a four-day
hiking trip each day she walked 20 more
than the distance that she walked the
day before
she walked a total of 27 kilometers
what is the distance sloan walked in the
first day of the trip and it says to
round our final answer to the nearest
kilometer so like always have a go at
this and see if you can figure out how
much she walked on the first day
all right well let's just call the
amount that you walked on the first day
a and then using a let's see if we can
set up an expression for how much she
walked in total and then that should be
equal to 27 and then hopefully we're
going to be able to solve for a
so the first day she walks eight
kilometers now how about the second day
well they tell us that each day
she walked 20 percent more than the
distance she walked the day before
so on the next day she's going to walk
20 percent more than a kilometers so
that's 1.2
times a
and what about the day after that her
third day well that's just going to be
1.2 times this the second day and so
that's going to be 1.2 times 1.2 or we
could say 1.2 squared
times a
and then how much on the fourth day and
that's she went on a four-day hiking
trip so that's the last day
well that's going to be 1.2 times the
third day so that's going to be
1.2 to the third power times a
so this is an expression in a on how
much she walked over the four days and
we know that she walked a total of 27
kilometers so this is going to be equal
to 27 kilometers
now you could solve for a over here you
could factor out the a and you could say
a
times 1 plus 1.2 plus 1.2 squared plus
1.2 to the third power is equal to 27
and then you could say that a is equal
to 27
over 1 plus 1.2 plus 1.2 squared plus
1.2 to the third power and we would need
a calculator to evaluate this but i'm
going to do a different technique a
technique that would work even if you
had 20 terms here you in theory could
also do this with 20 terms but it gets a
lot more complicated or if you had 200
terms
so the other way to approach this is use
the formula for a finite geometric
series what does it evaluate to and just
as a reminder the sum
of
first
n terms
it's going to be the first term which we
could call a
minus
the first term times our common ratio in
this case our common ratio is 1.2
because every successive term is 1.2
times the first
so our first term times our common ratio
to the nth power all of that over
1 minus the common ratio in other videos
we explain where this comes from we
prove this but here we can just apply it
we already know what our a is i use that
as our variable our common ratio in this
situation is going to be equal to 1.2
and our n
is going to be equal to 4.
another way i like to think about it is
it's our first term which we see right
over there
minus
the term that we did not get to if we
were to have a fifth term it would have
been that fifth term that we're
subtracting because we aren't getting to
a fourth power here the fifth term would
have been to the fourth power all of
that over one minus the common ratio
and so this left hand side of our
equation we could rewrite as our first
term minus our first term times our
common ratio 1.2 to the fourth power
all of that over
1 minus our common ratio and then that
could be equal to 27. let me scroll down
a little bit so we have some more space
to then solve this
and so let's see i can simplify this a
little bit we could this is going to be
equal to negative
0.2 our numerator we can factor out an a
and so this is going to be equal to a
times 1 minus 1.2 to the fourth power
and let's see we can multiply both the
numerator and the denominator by a
negative one and so this would get us to
a
times
a times and i'll i'll put the a out of
the out of the fraction a times so i'll
just swap the order here and get rid of
this negative 1.2 to the fourth power
minus 1
over
0.2
is equal to 27 again all i did is i took
the a out of the fraction so it's out
here and i multiplied the numerator and
the denominator by a negative the
numerator multiplied by negative would
swap these two and then multiplying
negative 0.2 times negative is just
positive 0.2
and so now i can just multiply both
sides times the reciprocal of this
so i'll do it here so 0.2
over 1.2 to the fourth minus 1 and then
here
0.2 over
1.2 to the fourth minus 1.
that cancels with that that cancels with
that that's exactly why i did that and
we're left with a is equal to
it is equal to i'll just write it in
yellow 27
times 0.2 all of that over 1.2 to the
fourth minus 1. and this expression
should give us the exact same value as
that expression we just saw
but this is useful even if we had 100
terms we could use this and so i'll get
the calculator out
this will give us
so
i will actually i'll evaluate this
denominator first so i'll have 1.2
to the fourth power which is equal to
minus 1 is equal to now it's in the
denominator so i could just take the
reciprocal of it and then multiply that
times 27
times 0.2
is equal to 5.029 now they want us to
round our answer to the nearest
kilometer so this is going to be
approximately equal to
approximately equal to five kilometers
that's how much approximately that she
would have traveled on the first day of
her hiking trip